all this cheese is for one pizza slice
look at that i'm gonna be here for a
while we are going for one slice the
size of four entire pizzas
[Music]
hello my name is alvin i am a tasty
producer and i love making giant crazy
food so i got a message from my friend
noah and this guy is a huge pizza guy
and he goes hey i saw your giant burger
video i'm gonna be in town tomorrow can
i request a giant pizza and the thing is
noah and i used to go to this pizza
place slices literally as large as your
head and noah is the only guy that i've
ever seen finish two of them it's just
starting to sound pretty exciting so i'm
like oh okay how big big big like dumb
big that's pretty big i've also been
getting a lot of requests to make a
giant pizza so i think i know what i'm
going to make today i'm like all right i
got you what's up dude yo how's it going
man how good how about you good to see
you i just got you my favorite pizza
yeah i want you to try it this looks
really good what do you like so much
about this slice of pizza dude well
first it's all about the crust has to be
chewy not too thick not too thin perfect
and the sauce a little sweet a little
salty really really smooth and has to
really taste like tomatoes toppings
cheese mozzarella gotta go with
pepperoni it's just a classic when all
those things come together you get this
beautiful slice of pepperoni pizza
oh
i'm gonna see if i can make you a giant
version of this so i'm gonna get to work
and i'll see you in a bit okay all right
man all right see you dude
okay let's make this pizza first thing
we gotta do gotta make the pizza dough
start with some warm water some sugar
i'm gonna add yeast to this little bad
boy let the yeast grow because yeast
doesn't grow dough won't grow
this recipe is actually a tasty 101
pizza recipe by claire and brenda i've
never made pizza before oh this recipe
doesn't look too bad seven cups of
seven cups of flour guys i take
everything back two three
four hope i have enough flour seven
that's a lot of flour we got some salt
olive oil
now we're gonna pour in
this yeast mixture okay on to the mixer
actually the recipe says to do by hand i
am one lazy person so claire and brenda
if you're watching and i mess up your
recipe i'm so sorry oh it's not turning
up please turn on what the heck
oh there it is all right we're back in
business this is going to go for 10
minutes and then we're going to see how
it is and we're going to make the rest
of it
that was actually looking really good
i'm just watching the stand mixer it is
a doing work right now i just think if i
had to do this by hand
it might be here for a while okay i'm
going to give you a little break okay
buddy so i think some nice dough you
still have to work the dough a little
bit because even though it's really
mixed together it needs to be in a
really nice circle shape so all right
let's get some flour oh gosh i missed i
totally missed get this dough
all out over here
this feels so nice yo this is like a
soft pillow i think i did a really good
job this entire batch of dough is
supposed to be enough dough for four
total pizzas cause usually six to eight
slices in a whole pizza right we're not
doing that we are going for one slice
that is the size
of four entire pizzas
a precious little goat ball so i think
he deserves a little break so let you
rest
while my dough takes a well-deserved nap
i'm gonna make this tomato sauce i'm
gonna use san marzano tomatoes because
these are really really good tomatoes
these are kind of like the ferrari of
canned tomatoes but this recipe makes
enough sauce for about two or three
pizzas but i'm just gonna double it just
in case because who knows
well there's some nice tomatoes look at
how smooth and peeled they are oh my
sorry i gotta crush you though
some sugar onion and garlic powder
oregano like gordon ramsay says some
salt some pepper
cracker lacquer starting a bubble
already okay let's chop this basil for
the basil you gotta roll it up real good
the tighter it is the better
smells like if my grandma was actually
italian and not chinese
there's still a lot of chunks in here
i'm gonna use one of my favorite toys
this is an immersion blender this thing
turns all your chunky problems into one
smooth solution so here we go
yes there we go that's what i like to
see
see that oh god i just got splattered it
was hot
that's better
that looks pretty good it's thickened a
bit texture is great okay sauce is done
let's talk cheese usually in pizza they
use breaded mozzarella basically kind of
like this corduso
i could is that going to be too easy
a little bit i want to make
essentially giant t-shirts how do you do
that
i'm not sure but i have an idea
mozzarella blox use this vegetable
peeler and a peel
giant cheese shreds off this
whoa
it actually kind of worked it's not bad
that's a cheese shred right that's like
a giant cheese shrimp
man
i love cheese this is a big cheese shred
a little cheese shred
i'm not gonna lie guys i'm crumbling
over the place it's gonna work out so
well that's okay we're just gonna shred
this cheese normally this grater is not
that good either
hold up
that's what i'm talking about
whoa wait this one this one makes giant
cheese shreds all right looks like our
plan was not so terrible after all look
at all that great cheese shrimp all this
cheese
is for one pizza slice just your
everyday pepperoni
but you guys actually know where
pepperoni comes from basically you take
a giant sausage when you cut it up i got
these bad boys these are some big
pepperonis you know i'm gonna be using
these why be normal when you can be like
that
okay let's see how my dough is looking
this guy grew so much let's take a look
at you
oh my
look at that it's so perfect oh
gotta tuck all those bad parts
underneath kind of like when you're
cleaning out your room shove everything
that doesn't look good under the bed
he does need to rest one last time put a
little blanket
um my precious dough ball we'll see you
an hour okay bye-bye
so to make this giant slice i actually
gonna make a slice the size of the
biggest tray i could find that we have
that actually fits in the oven see how
this goes
whoa we're doing this right how do the
professionals do it oh there we go
that's the stretch i'm talking about
thanks gravity you're the mvp
oh not bad for a first time i'm gonna be
here for a while
nope start shaping into its final form
it's been 25 years we now have airpods
three okay we're almost there i'm gonna
be able to play the piano so hard or
walk into a massage parlor and they're
gonna be like hey what kind of
experience you got i'll just pull up
this youtube video you gotta show the
does boss that's right oh that kind of
hurt maybe a rolling pin would be a
better idea progress check
it seems long enough oh it seems wide
enough next challenge is to get this
entire thing onto this tray a little bit
of semolina
oh come on
okay not a very clean landing the edges
are getting a little squished i'll
probably just turn them off and eat them
as scraps because i'm getting hungry at
this point this tray is about two and a
half feet long i did some math using
pythagoreans theorem a squared plus b
squared equals c squared and this comes
out to be
something along the lines of three feet
because this pizza is so big i want to
actually pre-bake the dough i'm scared
that if i put all the sauce and toppings
on right now in the middle just gonna be
very very soggy 500 degrees for about
five minutes okay here is the dough
that is pre-baked let's get toppings we
have giant mozzarella cheese shreds
homemade tomato sauce and giant
pepperonis first we gotta do the sauce i
like that don't get lost in the sauce
kids i might have made too much tomato
sauce that's okay i'll just make like 20
pizzas later time for the cheese gonna
make it rain oh wait it's 2019. we're
making it precipitate
i feel like those rappers and they're
just tossing hundred dollar bills in the
air that's who i am right now except i'm
tossing cheese when do i know when to
stop
man this is fun
[Music]
i officially ran out of cheese baked
pepperoni time
over here kind of feel like oprah you
get a pepperoni and you get a pepperoni
and i get a pepperoni one
i'm dishing out them stacks final one oh
would you look at that there's one left
over
this is a thing of beauty we have 18
giant pepperoni slices this is a serving
size for one person if you were not
me this is enough for a huge party of
like 20 people this is gonna go in the
oven 500 degrees for i want to say like
20 minutes and then we're gonna go eat
with no after that oh this is
this is really heavy
hey noah yeah you want your pizza all
right no this is the size of one
standard pizza is that right yeah it
looks right all right close your eyes
on the count of three one
two
three open your eyes noah oh my god
alvin oh my wow it's a big guy
do you like it yeah man dude wow look at
this look at this pizza dude it's a
little bigger than your normal pizza so
i got some leftover ingredients so i
made myself a pizza too
let's just get it right all right let's
go for it
all right cheers dude
cheers
[Music]
this is awesome you're doing really
great job the sauce you know the
pepperoni even got the cheese just right
then you can finish it you used to
finish two of those big slices back in
the day it'll take me a little time but
i think we can yeah we can use them out
i don't want any of this to go to waste
i got a couple of friends i just need to
cut off the bitten part and then we can
go and show the rest all right let's go
eat some pizza guys
today was super fun made a giant pizza i
think at the end of it all it came out
to be like three feet which is really
long just to see the love that people
have for pizza is just really awesome
and noah seemed pretty happy about it
too so that means i'm happy and the
thing is i love making these crazy
things so if you have a food that you
absolutely love hit me up leave a
comment send me a dm let me know what
your favorite food is and i will do my
very best to try and make a big version
of that for you until next time
peace
[Music]
you